elles ont apporté des idées plus fraîches et plus créatives.
Donc j'ai voulu savoir :
les plus diversifiées des organisations sont-elles vraiment plus innovantes,
et la diversité peut-elle être plus qu'une chose à laquelle on se conforme ?
Un réel avantage compétitif ?
Pour le savoir, nous avons fait une étude avec l'Université Technique de Munich.
Nous avons interrogé 171 entreprises en Allemagne, en Autriche et en Suisse,
et en ce moment-même, nous étendons nos recherches
à 1600 entreprises
dans cinq autre pays de par le monde.
Nous avons en fait demandé à ces entreprises deux choses :
leur degré d'innovation et leur degré de diversité.
Pour mesurer le premier,
nous leur avons demandé leur revenu sur innovation.
Le revenu sur innovation est la part des revenus obtenue
via de nouveaux produits et services ces trois dernières années,
nous n'avons donc pas demandé combien d'idées créatives ils ont eues
mais plutôt si ces idées se sont traduites en produits et services
qui font que l'entreprise réussit mieux jour après jour.
Pour mesurer la diversité, nous avons regardé six facteurs différents :
pays d'origine, âge et genre, entre autres.
Avant d'aller enquêter sur le terrain avec ces questions,
je me suis posée avec mon équipe
et nous avons discuté des résultats que nous pensions obtenir.
Pour le dire gentiment, on n'était pas optimiste.
La personne la plus sceptique de l'équipe pensait, ou entrevoyait
une réelle possibilité de ne rien trouver du tout.
La plupart restaient plus prudents,
et nous sommes tombés d'accord sur un « seulement si »,
c'est-à-dire que nous trouverions peut-être
un lien entre innovation et diversité
mais pas partout --
plutôt, seulement si certains critères sont remplis,
par exemple un style de leadership, un style de leadership très ouvert
qui permettrait aux gens de s'exprimer librement, sans risque et de contribuer.
Quelques mois après, réception des données,
et les résultats ont convaincu les plus sceptiques d'entre nous.
La réponse a été un oui sans équivoque,
pas de si, pas de mais.
Les données de notre échantillon ont montré
que les entreprises les plus diversifiées sont simplement plus innovantes, point.
Maintenant, la question légitime de l’œuf ou la poule se pose,
c'est-à-dire, les entreprises sont-elles vraiment plus innovantes
parce qu'elles ont une direction plus diversifiée,
ou l'inverse ?
Dans quel sens ça marche ?
Nous ne savons pas quel rôle jouent la corrélation ou la causalité
mais ce que nous savons, c'est que,
dans notre échantillon, les entreprises les plus diversifiées
sont plus innovantes,
et que les entreprises qui sont plus innovantes
ont des directions plus diversifiées.
On peut donc penser que ça marche dans les deux sens,
la diversité amenant l'innovation et l'innovation amenant la diversité.
Une fois que nous avons publié les résultats
nous avons été surpris des réactions dans les médias.
Nous avons reçu pas mal d'attention.
De quelque chose de plutôt factuel,
comme « Une part de femmes plus importante stimule l'innovation »
à quelque chose de plus sensationnaliste.
(Rires)
Comme vous pouvez le voir,
« Les femmes au foyer coûtent une fortune »
et, mon préféré à moi,
« Les femmes au foyer tuent l'innovation ».
Après tout, il n'y a pas de mauvaise publicité, n'est-ce pas ?
(Rires)
Après cette couverture médiatique,
nous avons commencé à recevoir des appels de cadres supérieurs
qui voulaient mieux comprendre,
en particulier - surprise, surprise - à propos de la diversité de genre.
J'ai tendance à ouvrir ces conversations en demandant,
« Bon, que pensez-vous de la situation de votre organisation aujourd'hui ? »
Et une réaction fréquente à ça c'est,
« Eh bien, on n'y est pas encore, mais on n'est pas si mal. »
Un cadre m'a dit, par exemple,
« Oh, on n'est pas si mal.
Un des membres de notre CA est une femme. »
(Rires)
Et vous riez...
(Applaudissements)
Vous riez, mais il marquait un point à être fier de ça,
parce qu'en Allemagne,
si vous avez une entreprise
et qu'un des membres du CA est une femme,
vous faîtes partie d'un groupe très select de 30
parmi les 100 entreprises côtées en bourse les plus importantes.
Les 70 autres entreprises ont un CA exclusivement masculin,
et pas même une de ces cent plus importantes entreprises cotées en bourse
a, à ce jour, une femme PDG.
Mais voilà l'idée particulièrement importante.
Ces quelques membres féminins du CA à elles seules,
ne feront pas de différence.
Nos données montrent que pour que la diversité ait un impact sur l'innovation,
vous devez avoir plus de 20% de femmes en position de direction.
Jetons un œil aux chiffres.
Comme vous pouvez le voir, nous avons scindé l'échantillon en trois groupes,
et les résultats sont assez spectaculaires.
Seul le groupe où plus de 20% des femmes sont en position de diriger,
voit le revenu sur innovation faire un net bond en avant
à des niveaux supérieurs à la moyenne.
Donc l'expérience et les données montrent qu'il y a besoin d'une certaine quantité
pour faire bouger les choses,
et des entreprises comme Alibaba, JP Morgan ou Apple
ont à ce jour déjà atteint ce palier.
Une autre réaction courante était,
« Eh bien, ça se résoudra avec le temps. »
J'ai toute la sympathie du monde pour ce point de vue,
car je pensais comme ça, moi aussi.
Maintenant, jetons encore une fois un œil à ceci et aux chiffres,
avec l'Allemagne pour exemple.
Laissez-moi d'abord vous donner les bonnes nouvelles.
Donc, la part des femmes diplômées de l'université
et avec au moins dix ans d'expérience professionnelle
a bien augmenté au cours des 20 dernières années,
ce qui signifie que le réservoir où choisir des leaders féminins
a augmenté au cours du temps,
et c'est super.
Maintenant, selon mon ancienne théorie,
la proportion de femmes leaders
devrait avoir augmenté plus ou moins en parallèle, non ?
Vérifions ce qui se passe en réalité.
Ce n'est même pas comparable,
ce qui signifie que j'avais complètement tort
et que ma génération,
votre génération,
la génération de femmes la mieux instruite de l'histoire,
nous n'avons pas réussi.
Nous avons échoué à obtenir de façon significative des postes de leader.
L'instruction ne s'est pas traduite par du leadership.
Ce fut une réalisation douloureuse pour moi
et cela m'a fait réaliser que,
si nous voulons changer ceci,
nous devons nous impliquer, et faire mieux.
Maintenant, que faire ?
Atteindre plus de 20% de leaders féminins
s'apparente à une tâche considérable pour beaucoup
ce qui est compréhensible, vu les antécédents.
Mais c'est faisable,
et beaucoup d'entreprises aujourd'hui font des progrès là-dessus
et le font avec succès.
Prenons la SAP, société de logiciel, comme exemple.
Ils avaient, en 2011, 19% de femmes à des postes de leaders,
pourtant ils ont décidé de faire mieux,
et ils ont fait ce qui se fait dans n'importe quel autre secteur
quand on veut s'améliorer.
Ils se sont fixé un objectif chiffré.
Donc ils se sont fixé un objectif de 25% pour 2017,
qu'ils viennent d'atteindre.
Les objectifs les ont rendus créatifs dans le développement des leaders
et l'usage de nouveaux réservoirs de recrutement.
Ils se sont même fixé un objectif de 30% de femmes leaders pour 2022.
Donc l'expérience démontre que c'est faisable,
et qu'au final,
on en revient à deux décisions prises chaque jour
dans chaque organisation par beaucoup d'entre nous :
qui embaucher et qui développer et promouvoir.
Je n'ai rien contre les programmes pour les femmes,
réseautage, mentorat, entraînements.
Tout ça est bien.
Mais ce sont ces deux décisions
qui au final envoient le signal de changement le plus puissant
dans toute organisation.
Je ne me suis jamais destinée à me faire l'avocate de la diversité.
Je suis une conseillère en affaires.
Mais à présent mon objectif est de changer le visage du leadership,
de le rendre plus diversifié--
et non pas comme une case à cocher
et que les chefs pensent s'être conformé à quelque chose
ou avoir été politiquement correct.
Mais parce qu'ils comprennent,
ils comprennent que la diversité rend leur organisation
plus innovante, meilleure.
Et en accueillant la diversité, en accueillant des talents divers,
nous offrons à tous une réelle opportunité.
Merci. Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)